it's no secret that mobile game pokemon
go has been vastly popular but how does
the money the game makes compared to
other successful mobile apps I'm Dave
and welcome to your game spot news
update according to a report from
research companies slice intelligence
Pokemon goes in game purchases made up
for forty-seven percent of total of the
entire mobile gaming market in a single
day on July the 10th in other words
Pokemon go almost made more revenue in a
single day than every other mobile app
combined in addition the report suggests
the app may be bringing in first time
mobile gaming spenders less than fifty
three percent of the users who spend
money in Pokemon go had made one or zero
mobile game purchases in the last six
months it's been estimated the Pokemon
go has already made 14 million dollars
the game was developed by niantic and
has already outperformed the developers
previous game ingress Pokemon goes
releases also made a big impact on
Nintendo's business outlook with company
shares rising a whopping eighty-six
percent in Tokyo this translates to a 17
billion dollar increase worth of market
capitalization so are you playing
Pokemon go if you are make sure you
check out gamespot for all the tips and
tricks and from on Pokemon go stay tuned
to gamespot com